now we do have some good news to report
tonight about the wife of the former
special ops translator who has been
hiding in afghanistan kirsten joyce
joins us with this very special update
she is safe words hk has been waiting to
share since i first met him two weeks
ago 15 days that i haven't had
probably no more than two hours
of sleep at night hk lives in las vegas
where he became a u.s citizen last year
he and his wife got married in
afghanistan and he's been working for a
year to supply her with the proper
documents to come to the states
after the taliban takeover he was scared
for his wife's life she had to hide out
just 10 minutes from the airport in
kabul there was times of over 9 000
people around the airport it was a
humanitarian disaster h.k worked day and
night with a variety of contacts to get
her safely to the airport folks he met
through his time as a translator helping
the u.s military in afghanistan for
nearly a decade his journey and efforts
being documented by his friend brian
johnson a guy who speaks five languages
that's beloved by the us military by
special forces that has worked with our
troops on the ground and loves this
country and now just wants to support
his community hk shared this photo with
us of his wife and brother-in-law when
they received news they would be safely
leaving afghanistan on monday
they are now in kuwait the last i heard
from the uh
embassy in kuwait the u.s embassy they
say that they're being processed and uh
once they're uh once they're getting
ready to take off from there and they'll
uh possibly send me you know a
description of the flight itinerary
where they're going bring them here
bring them to the you know where i am so
hopefully that happens i'll go see her
wherever she lands in the united states
and we'll go from there it's funny he
thinks he's going by himself that's cute
[Laughter]
although his wife and brother-in-law are
out of harm's way hk says his mission is
far from over my wife she's out of the
danger zone and i'm focused on saving
everybody else kirsten joyce 8 news now
h.k and bryant are currently in north
carolina hoping hk's wife lands there
but if not they'll go to wherever she
has flown h.k has lived in las vegas for
eight years his mother and father also
live here now we will bring you that
reunion of course when he gets to
embrace his wife on u.s soil